ah Hybris house good man it's bad I'm
here with the little sleepy little oh
yeah we left off we're gonna kill Khloe
Kardashian okay Khloe Khloe Kardashian's
lipstick wearing Nazi infant let's see
this little David Wow I can attack you
all right let's finish up the umbrella
call card how many [ __ ] circumcise
the umbilical cord yeah that's not too
bad nice not to buy it at all all right
let's see what butters can do Hammer
storms I should be good oh no oh no it's
oh it heals huh mommy they gotta get rid
of a-quaking should i smoke inside why
not yeah
I wasn't sure goodbye Hey look these
defenses down baby all right but us get
that son of a [ __ ] Oh
[Music]
what's okay it's an umbrella coat
oh [ __ ] don't heal don't heal don't Lea
all right well at least I'm blocking
that little [ __ ]
it's it dead no it's not dead yet what
the [ __ ] died already
call a cab David yeah by the power of
Joe
all right let's fart on that [ __ ] I
wanna be baptized I wish you could
customize my eye you're right there's no
nice not the infant okay oh [ __ ] like I
wish it had a little bit more in depth
it's still fun like I really really like
the gameplay I'm surprised I'm usually
not much for our piggies and [ __ ] like
that
I really need to chase that [ __ ]
outfit to Holy's day all right shut up
nice
[ __ ] disgusting yeah why not just hit
him that Mel slow him down I think I
suck yo dick sleeping goodbye let's
finish him or her I don't want to know
honestly that's so [ __ ] out yep it's
that alright now let's change these
stupid eyes outfit alright now we're
looking better [ __ ] that like this lower
that's my jam ah alright well I guess I
worry about us great day today okay well
what's our quest now let's see here I'm
so lost honestly return to Antony of
course I think she's this way oh yeah we
are gonna do all the side quests I have
decided I want to do a foot extensive
whatever I don't [ __ ] talk about okay
there it is I can either go I wanted
that zombie it's just like standing
there and smoking no don't say that bad
baby alright
what do you want girls want to thank you
for your help we can go see them again
whenever you're ready alright then let's
go
you know the drill Hey alright sparkling
sunshine and all that [ __ ] [ __ ] this
quest better be over soon the girls are
very thankful for you texting us the
abortion record we are one step away
from finding out which girl among us is
a two-faced [ __ ]
unfortunately the record-keeper at the
abortion clinic is from Paris and so
everything is written in French
whoever that's to face
we want to help you and the boys play
your game but we just can't have a
two-faced [ __ ] out there on the loose
just get these documents translated for
us and we promise we will join your army
sunshine well who can speak French isn't
that that one french guy that everyone
makes fun of yeah it's time for French
brothers to be offended why see if the
boys in cosmic yard can translate this
okay don't forget to bring the child you
never know when you need a cow and
another fire we need puts the coda and
this is like it's like that's it that's
it that's this room for Funkytown let me
take you down your funky tip okay I'm
sorry I'm sorry
this reminiscing why is it okay new rule
no more battles inside city wok mr.kim
complain to our parents new rules a lot
of this is huge thing going on in the
background with aliens and whatnot and
we just care about playing our stupid
game what did I miss it
here it is this is the place all right
here we go can someone translate too
powerful say I lost my contacts my maps
my friends list taken from me by the XI
ogre she has no soul you will help me
battle the XI ogre and reclaim my iPhone
perhaps you are one to be trusted
very well this is that cows mom the XI
ogre
gather round this must be something the
new kidneys are what language is that
some kind of strange Orchestra
I've seen this language before the
Kingdom to the north kingdom to the
north whatever is written on these
documents is somehow the key to us
recruiting the girl to our army is that
what you're trying to tell us new kid oh
he gives no sign getting that document
translate it isn't going to be easy to
breach the Kingdom to the north you'll
have to assume another identity your
name is no longer commander douchebag it
is now Larry Babinski from Cleveland the
quickest way to the kingdom to the north
is do the lost forest head north and
north again north and then north are we
gonna go to Canada better get a real
passport photo first or you won't make
it past border control we're going to
Canada Audrey wait is that a is that a
flag that I haven't discovered there we
go I got all of them cool
that's why I couldn't travel there I was
like what the [ __ ]
okay so we need a new passport photo
there where did we get that that has to
be here in the center right oh yeah
there's this photo I actually look
forward to this way I don't know it is
bad what that [ __ ] go to Stan's oh
that's the side quest we'll do that
later I wonder though if I can do the
side quest after I finish the main story
cuz I kind of want to finish the main
story parts kodiak's Auto pick up
drop-off Oh Oh Cartman is poo I remember
that episode that was awesome
hi here to get your passport photo taken
just head into the room there and we'll
get started alright I ever feeling like
something simple as just taking a photo
it's gonna be [ __ ] up step between the
lights please alright I say nice setup
you have here that's great okay smile oh
do you have anything hiding where could
you try something else on what's wrong
to this okay change out pay uh no tell
you what how about
no shirt at all let's try that of course
yeah that's gonna work better here we go
oh those pants don't work with the
lighting could you roll up your pants or
you know what just take take the pants
off - okay that's good
really nice yeah very nice
how about we lose the underwear you sick
son of a [ __ ] stop it you'll never take
never take all right let's just [ __ ]
kill em a lot of these fights come out
of nowhere a pedophile opieop i all
right why is it called pedo file isn't
[ __ ] me
it's pedophile say I because I know
these things okay no it isn't actually
attack that's Lobby ah you [ __ ]
paddle actually like that Wow good job
kid you're quite the fighter yeah all
right let's get this over with
say cheese Congrats kid you have your
first Passport
thank you thank you thank you wait for
what Bryce I have to put on the damn
clothes again definitely the best setup
that I have
make your way to catch yeah cuz I saw a
Canada it's actually on the man's it's
kind of funny hi Congrats kid you have
your first Passport thank you thank you
very much
you see here you just so dumb how the
hell do I make your way through the laws
okay
sure why not this should be a fast
travel here there we go
I've upgrades available alright let's
just go
so Todd that he's my friend now oh okay
because I I'm only here to tell people
how much it sucks when people do that or
headphones but oh yeah I don't have to
go through there now okay we'll get to
those later
[Music]
use two ah house easy haven't we been
here before I haven't it's the first
time that's awesome I just have to go
north all right son on them that's gonna
be hard
ah [ __ ] what what the [ __ ] okay well hey
I take it I feel it's over here shut up
my sense of direction is impeccable what
is this that's [ __ ] I got em Nancy's
enemies everywhere I'm gonna have to put
you down
goddamn somebody attacks even got that
guy even has a hair cut down and
everything okay I'm sorry but I'm gonna
have to plague of Egypt you [ __ ]
and the frogs aren't that great keep
that in mind
what is stand you again whoa stay in the
man what the hell do I do
awesome Haley did any damage oh no he's
gonna bite me not biting me I have to
take Stan and I'm not I like standing
the show but it's not that great this is
Scott Kyle cuz I don't think we used him
all right let's just keep walking Norv
and see if we'll make it there I'm
following you here I hope you weren't
following me yeah oh oh okay I love the
Canadians in this show so does all
Canadians have heads like that what is
it what is the history like Canada why
like why is it separate from from
America I don't understand
how did that happen I guess it's owned
by the French let it French colleagues
and then I'm sorry for being ignorant I
honestly don't know oh that's RPG all
right hated land
and no I don't know that I what am I
should I go in Ottawa come around I am I
guess not
best day here in time those dialogues
can rip your anus upon me a second okay
welcome to the shop can I interest you
in my yes thank you it's gonna be like
this the entire time I don't have any
Canadian dollars or luck
[Music]
oh yeah they have to do that
oh she's kawaii welcome to the Ottawa
Clinic are you here Friday come back
whenever you need healing or another HIV
okay he's gonna have on money right no
the [ __ ] is going on
oh hell the prince and princess of
Canada oh well well what have we here I
hero from the south not just anyone can
pass the guard at the great border
you must have beaten the odds and
obtained I am the Prince of Canada and
this is my lovely wife how can I help
you so immature
hmm sorry but I don't know what this
says I've seen this language before but
I believe it's only spoken in a specific
part of Canada I suggest you travel west
of here and seek out the Earl of
Winnipeg he can tell you where in Canada
they speak this freakish talk but I
won't use the wilderness of Canada is
filled with dire wolves
you know what dire wolves all right
they're like wolves but they're dire oh
yeah
the princess squeeze price when she met
you that is a great honor with the
prince and princess would you like to a
tenth or six five five seventh all right
there you go
you can exit right through that I would
have picked a pipe ends like a horn I
supposed to know the prince is Crete
right
oh no direwolves okay well I guess gonna
have to fight someone they will rip your
anus for [ __ ] sake you just have to
turn around and [ __ ] on me let's do a
lot of damage
especially if you don't know how to
block that was close did he poop below
that's nice come on you're wasting my
damn time
did Kyle make it seriously with Sarah
health I'm Sharon there you can do that
that's awesome okay we're just gonna
have to finish these guys off oh they're
both low health Carly
the cow bug out or something look at in
the [ __ ] all right I'll take it
okay I'm gonna switch out Kyle Kazan oh
oh okay we have a farm in I don't know
all right cool all right chicken here
welcome to Winnipeg this is a
conservative Township so mind your P's
and Q's some attacks dangerous way he's
named Polly is diovan sir man welcome to
the shop you know what Winnipeg is known
for but never the will [ __ ] happen here
this poor citizen was killed by a
diamond you know when a diver is back
it's like a man
I heard they say that two Canadian monks
live on a secluded island in the middle
of Vancouver ah yes this writing is
definitely Canadian but why should I
help a phono in Winnipeg is completely
overrun with daya bass tell you what
kill up all the dye fans in the north of
town and I'll help you however I can
okay oh we're supposed to check here for
the direwolf not you guys and not me all
right now I get it
oh wow
no no not beer boss Oh God oh no no Cod
man oh not the Canadian grieving again
and they were trying to be polite and
[ __ ] but okay I need karma in the line
for this one
Mitaka the great taco
[Music]
this combo with Cartman's now not the
magic missle that sound this is like the
best thing ever
[ __ ]
not the Canadian greeting the greeting
of them canary angry
[ __ ] yeah caramel is pretty good man
gotta say we're done with this [ __ ]
by Snider okay the thing would even
cover my damn screen and I could have
done something
you know what a diet is right yes I do
know I actually just killed one look at
all these dire bad pounds now I can
finally make a diary all right give me
that
what is it say this is actually written
in the language of eastern canadian
minister of montreal can translate it
but I'm afraid the prince has imprisoned
the minister of montreal in the
conference of Quebec I will speak with
the Prince returned to him and he should
let you speak with the most in all of
Canada oh he's my friend now I didn't
know they had a Facebook in Canada I'm
just kidding okay all right I respect
that no no yeah speak to the Prince
again I wonder how many times the
princess will provide me today I hope
from lucky maybe two times again it was
so nice she's quite the lady right the
lady indeed all right I'd like to help
you but I think this might be another
ploy by the Bishop of Banff to have
Montreal allowed back into the kingdom
Canadians think our nation should be
united again my lord the Bishop of Banff
is a liberal he does these things just
to make life difficult for me I must ask
you to perform another noble quest go to
Banff and kill the bishop the bishop of
Arts in your talk you kill the fish of a
fan for me and bring me his balls as
proof do this and I shall allow you into
the catacombs of Quebec big guys
Canadians are so awesome in this
[Music]
hi Prez you know what I'm sorry but I
have to end this episode here hope you
guys enjoyed watching if you did leave a
like it helps me out a lot and it makes
us all feel good in the butt
alright see you next one
[Music]